so welcome Abram and thank you so much
for joining us well thank you Chloe and
Whitney and thank you everyone for for
joining this this conversation and so a
few weeks ago on on the same day we
learned about the brutal murder of
George Floyd we also learned that a
white woman in Central Park who chose
not to leash her dog and was told by a
black man nearby that she needed to
leash or dog instead decided to threaten
this black male instead decided to call
the police and claimed that her life was
being threatened and of course when we
learned about that through a video many
Americans were outraged and this woman
Amy Cooper ended up going on national TV
and saying like countless other
Americans have said right after they
engaged in a racist that I am NOT racist
and I say countless Americans because
when you really think about the history
of Americans expressing racist ideas
supporting racist policies you're really
talking about a history of people who
have claimed they're not racist because
everyone claims that they're not racist
whether we're talking about the Amy
Cooper's of the world whether we're
talking about Donald Trump who right
after he said that majority black
Baltimore is a rat road an infested mess
that no human being would want to live
in and he was challenged as is being
racist he said actually I'm the least
racist person anywhere in the world and
and so really the heartbeat of racism
itself has has always been denial and
and the sound of that heartbeat has
always been I'm not racist and so what
I'm trying to do with my work is to
really get Americans to eliminate the
concept of not racist from their
vocabulary and realize we're either
being racist
or anti-racist we're either expressing
ideas that suggest certain racial groups
are better or worse than others superior
or inferior than others are either being
racist or being anti racist we're
expressing the racial expressing notions
that the racial groups are equals
despite any cultural and ethnic
differences we're either supporting
policies that are leading to racial
inequities and injustice like we saw in
Louisville where Brianna Taylor was
murdered or we're supporting policies
and pushing policies that are leading to
justice and inequity for all and so I
think we should be very clear about
whether we're expressing racist ideas
about whether we're expressing
supporting racist policies and admit
when we are because to be anti-racist is
to admit when we expressed a racist idea
is to say you know what when I was doing
that in Central Park I was indeed being
racist but I'm gonna change I'm gonna
strive to be anti-racist and to be
racist is to constantly deny the racial
inequities that pervade American society
to constantly deny the racist ideas that
pervade American minds and so I want to
build a just and equitable Society and
and the only way we're going to even
begin that process is if we admit our
racism and start building an anti-racist
world thank you
thank you so much for that you know your
your book how to be an anti-racist has
become a best-seller in light of what's
been happening and and you've been
speaking a bit too you know the ways in
which anti racism in racism are the only
two polar opposite ways to hold a view
on racism I'm curious if you could talk
a little bit more about what the basic
tenets of anti racism are for people who
aren't as familiar with it in terms of
how they can be anti-racist sure and so
I mentioned in my talk that the
heartbeat of racism is is denial and
really the heartbeat of anti racism is
confession is the recognition that to
grow up in this society is to literally
at some point in our lives
probably internalize ideas that are
racist ideas that suggest certain racial
groups are are better or worse than
others and because we believe in racial
hierarchy because Americans have been
systematically taught that black people
are more dangerous when that black
people are more criminal like when we
live in a society where black people of
40% of the National incarcerated
population that's going to seem normal
to people when we live in a society in a
city like Minneapolis where black people
are 20% of the population but more than
60% of the people being subjected to
police shootings it's gonna seem normal
and so to be anti-racist is to believe
that there's nothing wrong or inferior
about black people or any other racial
group there's nothing dangerous about
black people or any other racial group
and so when we see these racial
disparities all around us we see them as
abnormal and and then we start to figure
out okay what policies are behind so
many black people are being killed by
police what policies are behind so many
Latinas people being disproportionately
infected with Coe bid how can I be a
part of the
struggle to upend those policies and
replace them with more anti-racist
policies and so it sounds like you you
do make that distinction then between
not racist and anti-racist and because
could you talk a little bit more about
that and break that down how what is the
difference between the two in the most
simplest way a not racist is a racist
who is in denial and an anti-racist is
someone who is willing to admit the
times in which they're being racist and
who is willing to recognize the
inequities and the problems of racial
problems of our society and who is
willing to challenge those racial
inequities by challenging policy and so
I'm saying this because let literally
slaveholders slave traders imagine that
their ideas in our terms were not racist
they would say things like black people
are the curse descendants of him and
they're cursed forever into enslavement
this isn't I'm not racist this is God's
law they would say things like you know
based on science based on ethnology
based on Natural History black people by
nature are predisposed to slavery and
civility this is nature's law I'm not
racist I'm actually doing what nature
said I'm supposed to be doing and so
this this construct of being not racist
and denying one's racism goes all the
way back to the origins of this country
yeah and why do you think it has been so
hard for some people now to still accept
that neutrality is not enough when it
comes to racism I think because it takes
a lot of work to be anti-racist it takes
you have to be very vulnerable right you
have to be willing to admit that you
were wrong you have to be willing to
admit that you that if you have more if
you're white for instance and and you
have more it may not be because you are
more you have to admit that yeah you've
worked hard pretend
in your life but you also have certain
advantages which provided you with with
opportunities that other people did not
have you have to admit those things and
it's very difficult for people to be
publicly and even privately
self-critical I think it's also the case
of and I should have probably led with
this how people define racist and so
people tend to define racist
as like a fixed category as an identity
this is essential to who a person is it
if someone becomes a racist and and and
so therefore and then they also connect
a racist with a bad evil person they
connect a racist with a Ku Klux Klan's
man or woman they and they're like I'm
not in the Ku Klux Klan I'm not a bad
person and I've done good things in my
life I've done good things to people of
color and so therefore I can't be racist
I'm not that that's not my identity but
that's actually not how we should be
defining racist racist is a descriptive
term it describes what a person is
saying we're doing in any given moment
and so when a person in one moment is
expressing a racist idea in that moment
they're being racist when they're saying
black people are lazy if in the very
next moment they're appreciating the
cultures of native native people they're
being anti-racist and you know we're
gonna get to some questions from our
community in a moment but I think when a
lot of people hear this this idea that
you're putting forward this idea of anti
racism there's this feeling that this is
something that only concerns the white
community and so could you speak a
little bit to how black the black
community and non non-white other ethnic
minorities can participate in and think
about this idea of anti racism
sure so if white Americans commonly say
I'm not racist people of color commonly
say I can't be racist because I'm a
person of color and and then some
the some people of color say they can't
be racist because they have no power and
and and so first and foremost what I've
tried to do in my work is to push back
against this idea that people of color
have no power there's nothing more
disempowering to say or to think as a
person of color then to say you have no
power people of color have long utilized
the most basic power that every human
being has and that's the power to resist
policy and path that's the power to
resist racist policies that's the power
to resist the racist society but if
you're a person of color and you believe
that people coming here from Honduras
and El Salvador are invading this
country you believe that these latina
accents are animals and rapists then
you're certainly not if you're black or
Asian or Native going to be a part of
the struggle to you know to defend
latina immigrants to recognize that
latina X immigrants have much to give to
this country as any other group of
people you're going to view these people
as taken away your jobs and so therefore
you're going to support racist rhetoric
you're gonna support racist policies and
even though that is probably going to be
harming you in other words is going to
be harming if you're black immigrants
coming from Haiti and in Nigeria if
you're Asian immigrants coming from from
from from India and so I think it's
critically important for even people of
color to realize they have the power to
resist and if when when people of color
view other people of color as the
problem they're not going to view racism
as the problem and anyone who is not
viewing racism as the problem is is is
not being anti-racist
you touch on this a bit in your in your
beginning talk here but you know you've
talked about how racism is the reason
that black communities and communities
of color are systemically disadvantaged
in America which has led to so many more
deaths from co19 in those communities
and yet the media is often placing the
blame on people of color for their
vulnerability to owner ability to
illness so I'm curious in in line with
that what is the relationship between
anti racism and the potential for a
systemic change I think it's I think
it's a direct relationship because when
you are when you believe and have
consumed racist ideas you're not gonna
even believe change is necessary because
you're gonna believe that racial
inequality is normal or you're not gonna
believe change is possible in other
words you're going to believe that the
reason why black people are being killed
by police at at such high rates or or
the reason why that the next people are
being infected at such higher rates is
because there's something wrong with
them and nothing can be changed and and
so you wouldn't even begin to even see
the need for systemic structural change
let alone be a part of the struggle for
systemic structural change and so to be
anti-racist again is to recognize that
there's only two causes of racial
inequity either there's something wrong
with people or there's something wrong
with power and policy and if you realize
that there's nothing wrong with any
group of people and I keep mentioning
groups you know I'm not saying
individuals there's certainly black
individuals who didn't take coronavirus
seriously which is one of the reasons
why they were infected but there are
white people who didn't take coronavirus
seriously there's no one has ever proven
actually studies have shown that black
people were more likely to take the
coronavirus seriously then then then
white people we're not talking about
individuals here and we certainly should
not be individualizing groups we
we should not be looking at the
individual behavior of one Latinas
personal one black person in saying
they're representatives of the group
that's a racist idea in and of itself
and so I'm talking about groups and and
and if you believe the groups are equals
then the only other alternative the only
other explanation to persisting inequity
and injustice is power and policy and
and to then spend your time transforming
and challenging power and policy is to
spend your time being anti-racist so we
have some questions that are coming in
from the audience first one here is a
community member that asks when we talk
about white privilege we talk also about
the privilege not to have the difficult
conversations do you feel that's
starting to change I hope so
and because I think that white white
Americans too need to simultaneously
recognize their privileges the
privileges that they have accrued as a
result of their whiteness and and the
only way in which they're going to be
able to do that is by initiating and
having these conversations but then they
also should recognize that that yes they
have more white Americans have more due
to racist policy but the question I
think white Americans should be having
particularly when they're having these
conversations among themselves is would
we have a more equity had a more
equitable Society
would we have more because what I'm
asking is that you know white Americans
have more because of racism but there
are other groups of people in other
Western democracies who have more than
white Americans and then you start to
ask the question why is it that people
in other countries have have free health
care why is it that they have paid
family leave why is it that they have a
massive safety net why is it that we do
not and the answer to
one of the major answers to why we do
not here have is racism
one of the major answers as to why
Donald Trump is President of the United
States is racism and so we're not really
to be I'm not really asking white
Americans to be altruistic in order to
be anti-racist we're we're really asking
people to have intelligent self-interest
those four million I should say five
million poor whites in 1860 whose
poverty was the direct result of the
riches of a few thousand white slave
holding families in order to challenge
slavery weren't saying you know we need
to be you to be altruistic no we
actually need you to do what's in your
best in your self-interest those tens of
millions of Americans white Americans
who've lost their jobs as a result of
this pandemic
we're not asking him to to be altruistic
we're asking them to realize that if we
had a different type of government with
a different set of priorities then then
they would be much better off right now
I'm sorry I you know don't get me
started
no we're grateful thank you and in line
with that you know obviously these these
protests in this movement have led to
some progress the removal of Confederate
monuments you know then Minneapolis City
Council pledging to dismantle the police
department etc but what do you view as
the greatest priority on a policy level
as this fight for justice continues I
mean are there any ways that we could
learn from other countries I don't
actually think necessarily there's a
singular sort of policy priority I mean
if someone was to force me to to answer
I would probably say to and and and that
is high-quality free health care for all
and and so when I say high quality I'm
not just talking about Medicaid Medicare
for all I'm talking about a simultaneous
area on which in rule Southwest Georgia
where the people are predominantly black
and have some of the highest death rates
in the country those counties in
southwest Georgia from Coalville that
they would have access to healthcare as
high quality as people do in in Atlanta
in New York City and and then
simultaneously that that access that
that healthcare would be free so many
Americans not only of course are dying
this year kovat but also of heart
disease and cancer which are the number
one killers before COBIT of americans
and they're disproportionately black and
so I would say that and then secondarily
I would say reparations and many
Americans claim that they believe in
racial equality they they want to bring
about racial equality
many Americans recognize just how
critical economic livelihood is for
every person in this country in this
economic system but then many Americans
reject or are not supportive of
reparations and so we have a situation
in which white Americans are last I
checked the median wealth is 10 times
the median wealth of black Americans and
according to a recent study by 2050 3
right between now I should say in 2050
three white median wealth is projected
to grow and this was before the
discouraged but and and the and black
median wealth is expected to redline at
zero dollars Anette based on this
current recession that may be pushed up
a decade and and so we not only have a
racial wealth gap but we have a racial
wealth gap that's growing and so for
those Americans who claim they are
committed to racial equality who also
recognize the importance of economic
livelihood and who also know that wealth
is in
heritage and the majority of wealth is
inherited and and when you think of the
inheritance you're thinking of past in
the past policies that that many
Americans consider to be racist whether
it's slavery or even redlining
how would we even begin to close this
growing racial wealth gap without a
massive program like reparations well
sort of connected to this idea of
thinking about wealth disparity in
wealth and equality in this country we
have a question from committee member
danfa Deena pearls she asks how do you
suggest liberal white organizations
effectively address problems of racism
within the work environment particularly
in environments where people remain
silent
in the face of racism or make token
statements without looking internally
sure and so I would I would make a few
suggestions one for several decades now
every workplace has publicly pledged a
commitment to diversity typically they
have diversity statements I would
basically rip up those diversity
statements and write a new statement and
that's a statement committed to anti
racism and in that statement you would
clearly define what a racist idea is
what an anti-racist idea is what a
racist policy is and what an anti-racist
policy is and you would state as a
workplace that you're committed to
having a culture of anti-racist ideas
and having a culture having an
institution made up of anti-racist
policies and so then everybody can
measure everyone's ideas and the
policies of that workplace based on that
document and and I think that that could
begin the process of transformation I
also think it's critically important for
for workplaces to to not only sort of
diversify their staff but diversify
their upper administration
and and I think that's absolutely
critical as well we have some more
questions coming in from the audience we
had one from Melissa Mahoney who's
asking
Donald Trump seems to be making
supporting black lives matters a
partisan issue for example making fun of
Mitt Romney for participating in a
peaceful protest how do we uncouple this
to make it non partisan well I mean I I
think that to say the lives of black
people is a democratic declaration it's
simultaneously stating that Republicans
do not value black lives and so I mean
because if that's essentially what what
Donald Trump is saying if if he's
stating that there's a problem with
marching for black lives then what is
the solution the solution is not
marching there was the other alternative
the other alternative is not marching
for black lives the other alternative is
not caring when black people die of
police violence or copia and and and so
to me if it's the way in which we we
make this a non partisan issue is to
strike back or argue back in that way
and obviously Republicans in a claim
they're not saying that but it's a very
simple thing either you believe black
lives matter or you don't and if you
believe black lives matter because you
believe in human rights and you believe
in the human right for black people and
all people to live and to not have to
fear police violence and and not have to
fear this state and not have to fear
that a peaceful process is going to be
broken up because some politician wants
to get a campaign off then then you're
going to institute policy that that
shows it or you're not
I'm gonna ask a question that just about
how people can think about anti racism
and how they can actually bring this
into their into their lives you know I I
imagine that a lot of folks they hear
this and they're like oh you know I have
to I have to think be really thoughtful
about how my actions and my words are
perceived what does the perceived
intention behind what it is that I'm
saying and that that may feel exhausting
and I think that connects even to this
idea of policy and so I'm curious you
know there is an a huge element of
thoughtfulness that comes along with
this work of being anti-racist and you
know what is your reaction in response
to those who feel concerned about the
the mental exhaustion from having to
constantly think about how your actions
may hurt or harm others so I think part
of the concern that people have about
mental extraordin is this idea that they
don't ever want to make a mistake and
and and i think i think to be
anti-racist is is to make mistakes it is
to they'll recognize when we make a
mistake to for us it's what's critical
is to have those very clear definitions
so that we can assess our words we can
assess our deeds and when we make a
mistake we just own up to and say you
know what that was a racist idea you
know what I was supporting a racist
policy but I'm going to change the other
thing I think is important for us to
realize is in many ways we are addicted
and when I say we individuals and
certainly in this country is it is
addicted to racism and and that's one of
the reasons why for so many people
they're just in denial people are
usually deny their addictions and but
then once we realize that we have this
addiction everyone who has been addicted
you know you talk to you know
and family members who who are
overcoming an addiction to substance
abuse they're not going to say that
they're just healed that they don't have
to think about this regularly they you
know someone who is overcoming
alcoholism is going to say you know what
this is a day-by-day process and I'm
take a day by day and moment by moment
and and I'm actually yes it's difficult
to restrain myself from reverting back
to what I'm addicted to but at the same
time it's liberating it's free because
I'm no longer having to wallow in that
addiction and so I think and I'm no
longer having to hurt people
due to my addiction I think that's
critical you know I think we we spent so
much time thinking about how we feel and
in less time thinking about how our
actions and ideas make others feel and I
think that's one thing that the George
Floyd video forced Americans to do was
to really see and hear especially how
someone feels as a result of their
racism we have another question from the
audience
this one is asking about can you speak
to the intersectionality between the
work of anti racism feminism and gay
rights how does the work of anti racism
relate and affect the work for these
other human rights issues sure so I when
I I define a racist idea has any idea
that suggests a racial group is superior
or inferior to another racial group in
any way and I use the term racial group
as opposed to race because every race is
a collection of racialized
intersectional groups and so you have
black women and and black men and you
have black heterosexuals and and black
queer people just as you have latina
acts women
and white women and and an Asian men and
and what's critical for us to understand
is they there hasn't just been racist
ideas that have targeted let's say black
people there's been racist ideas that
have been developed and have targeted
black women that have targeted black
lesbians that have targeted blacks
transgender women and oftentimes these
racist ideas targeting these
intersectional groups are intersecting
with other forms of bigotry that is also
targeting these groups to give an
example about black women one of the
oldest racist ideas about black women
was this idea that they're inferior
women or that they're not even women at
all and in that they're inferior to
white women who are the pinnacle of
womanhood and and that idea has
intersected with this with this sexist
idea that suggests that women are weak
that the more weak a person is a woman
is the more woman she is and and the
more the stronger a woman is the more
masculine she is these these two ideas
have intersected to constantly sort of
degrade black women as these as this
idea of the strong black masculine woman
who is inferior to the weak white woman
and so the only way to really understand
these constructs of a weak super
feminine white woman and a strong hyper
masculine black women is to understand
sexist ideas is to reject sexist sexist
ideas and I'll say very quickly the same
goes for the intersection of racism in
homophobia in which black queer people
who have been subjected to this idea
that they are more hyper sexual because
there's this idea of of queer people as
being more hyper sexual than
heterosexuals and so black queer people
have been tagged as more hyper sexual
than white queer people and black
heterosexuals
and and and if you can't really see that
and understand that and reject that if
you're not rejecting and understanding
and challenging homophobia to and you
know to this point of challenging we
have another question from Miriam Mohit
in our community who asks how do you see
cancel culture and anti racism
interacting for example when someone did
something obviously racist in the past
and it comes to light how do we respond
to well so I think it's very very
complex I do obviously encourage people
to transform themselves to change to
admit those times in which they were
being racists and and so obviously we as
a community have to give people that
ability to do that you know we can't
when someone admits that they were being
racist we can't immediately obviously
cancel them but but I also think that
there are people who do something so
egregious and there are people who are
so unwilling to recognize how egregious
what they just did is so in a particular
moment so not just the horrible vicious
act but then on top of that the refusal
to even admit the horrible you know
vicious act you know in that case I
could see how people would literally
want to cancel them and and and I think
that we we have to on the other hand we
have to have some sort of consequence
public consequence cultural consequence
for people acting in a rant racist
manner especially in an extremely
egregious way and for many people they
decided you know what I'm just gonna
cancel folks you know I'm not going to
necessarily critique them but I do think
we should try to figure out a way the
discern those who are refusing to trance
form themselves and those who made a
mistake and recognized it and truly are
committed to transforming themselves
yeah I mean you know one of the concerns
many activists have been expressing is
that the energy behind the black lives
matter movement has to stay high for
anti-racist changed sure they take place
I think that applies what you just said
as well and I guess I'm curious what
your opinion is on you know when the
protests start to wane and people's
donation matching campaigns fade into
the background how can we all ensure
that this conversation about anti racism
stays central sure
so in how to be an anti-racist in one of
the final chapters is this chapter
called failure I talked about what I
call feelings advocacy and and this is
people feeling bad about what's
happening what happened to George Floyd
or or what happened to Ahmad Aubry or
what happened to Brianna Terrell or they
they just feel bad about this country
and where this country is headed and and
so the way they go about feeling better
is by coming to a demonstration the way
they go about feeling better is by
donating to a particular organization
the way they go about feeling better is
it's reading a book and and so if this
is where what many Americans are doing
then once they feel better in other
words once the individual feels better
through their participation in book
clubs or or demonstrations or donation
campaigns then nothing is going to
change except what their own fields and
so we need to move past our feelings and
and this isn't to say that people
shouldn't feel bad but we should use our
feelings how horrible we feel about what
is going on too
into place put into practice sort of
policies race anti-racist power and
policy in other words our feelings
should be driving us they shouldn't be
the end-all
this should not be about making us feel
better this should be about transforming
this country and and we need to keep our
eyes on transforming this country
because if we don't then and once people
feel better after this is all over then
then we'll be back to the same situation
of being horrified by another video and
then feeling bad and then the cycle will
only continue you know I think when we
think about what sort of changes we can
implement and how we could make this
system work better make our governments
work better make our police work better
you know are there models in other
countries where you know obviously the
history in the United States is is
really unique in terms of thinking about
race and oppression but you know when
you look to other other nations and
other cultures are there are there
models that you look at as examples that
we could potentially implement here I
mean there's so many you know they're
there countries in which police officers
don't wear weapons they're there
countries who have just who have more
people than the United States but but
less prisoners there countries who try
to fight violent crime not with more
police in prisons but with more jobs and
more opportunities because they know and
see that the cut that the communities
with the highest levels of violent crime
tend to be communities with high levels
of poverty and in in long-term
unemployment I I think that and then
obviously other countries provides
pretty sizable social safety nets for
people such that people are not
committing crimes out of poverty and so
it's just that people are not quitting
crimes out of despair
and and so I think that it's critically
important for us to first and foremost
think through okay if there's nothing
wrong with the people then how can we go
about reducing police violence how can
we go about reducing how racial health
inequities what policies you know can we
change what policies have worked these
are the types of questions we we need to
be asking because there's never really
been anything wrong with the people in
your Atlantic piece called who gets to
be afraid in America you wrote what I am
a black male should not matter who I am
should matter and I feel that's you know
kind of what you're saying that in other
places maybe that's more possible and
that I'm curious when you imagine a
country in which who you mattered who
you are mattered first what does that
look like well what it looks like for me
as a black American is that people do
not view me as dangerous and thereby
make my existence dangerous it allows me
to to walk around this this country and
to not believe that people are going to
fear me because of the color of my skin
it allows me to believe you know what I
didn't get that job because I could have
done better on my interview not because
of the color of my skin
it allows me to to a country where
there's racial equity a country where
there's racial justice you know a
country where there's shared opportunity
you know a country where African
American culture and and Native American
culture and and the cultures of of
mexican-americans and and Korean
Americans are all valued equally that no
one's being asked to assimilate into
white American culture there's no such
thing as a standard professional where
there there's no such thing as well you
need to learn how to speak English in
order to be an American
and you know we would truly not only
have equity and injustice for all but we
would somehow have found a way to
appreciate difference to appreciate all
of the human ethnic and cultural
difference that exists in the United
States I mean this is what could make
this country great in which we literally
become a country where you could
literally travel around this country and
learn about cultures from all over the
world and appreciate those cultures and
and understand even your own culture
from the from from from what other
people are doing I mean you know there's
so much beauty here amid all this pain
and I just want to sort of peel away in
and remove away you know all of those
scams of racist policies so that people
can heal and so that we can see true
beauty and even when you think about
this moment where do you see that on the
scope of progress towards reaching that
attribute II well I think for me I
always see progress in resistance in
demonstrations and and know just because
key people are calling from town squares
and and from city halls for progressive
systemic change that that changes here
but people are calling and people are
calling in small towns and big cities
and people are calling from places we've
heard of and in places we need to have
heard of you know people are calling for
change and people are fed up I mean
we're living in a time which we're
facing a viral pandemic a racial
pandemic within that viral pandemic of
people of color disproportionately being
infected in dying even in economic
pandemic with over 40 million Americans
having lost or having lost their jobs
and and certainly this pandemic of
police violence and then people
demonstrating against police violence
only to suffer police
at demonstrations I mean people see
there's a fundamental problem here and
there's a problem that can be solved
there's a there's an America that can be
created and people are calling for this
and and and that is always the beginning
the beginning is what we're experiencing
now I think that this next audience
question follows well from that which is
what gives you hope right now
so certainly resistance to racism has
always given me hope and so even if
let's say six months ago we were not in
a time in which almost every night you
know all over this country people were
demonstrating against racism but I could
just look to history when when people
are resisting and and so resistance
always brings me hope because it is R
always resistance that that and it's of
course it's stormy but what the rainbow
is typically on the other side but I'm
also I also received hope
philosophically because I know that in
order to bring about change we have to
believe in change there's just no way a
change maker can be cynical is it I mean
it's impossible so I know I have to
believe in change in order to bring it
about I mean and we have another
question here which addresses some of
the things you talked about before in
terms of this structural change that we
need to bring about you know from Miriam
in terms of putting into practice the
transformative policies is then the most
important thing to allow devote the
right people into office at every level
can make those structural changes happen
so I think that that is part of it I
certainly think we should we should vote
into office people who from school
boards to the president of United States
people are committed to instituting
anti-racist policies that that lead to
equity and and and justice
and and I think that that's critically
important and and I but I don't I don't
think that we should really should think
that that's the only thing we should be
focused on or the only thing that we
should be doing and and there are
institutions there are neighborhoods
that need to be transformed that aren't
to a certain extent outside of the
purview of a policy maker in an you know
who's an elected official there are
administrators in CEOs and and
presidents who have the power to
transform policies within their spheres
within their institutions and and so we
should be focused there the last thing
I'll say about voting is I wrote a
series of pieces for the Atlantic early
this year that sought to get Americans
thinking about who I call the other
swing voter and and not the traditional
swing voter who swings from Republican
to Democrat who are primarily older and
and white I'm talking about this the
people who swing from voting Democrat to
not voting at all and these people are
typically younger and they're typically
people of color but they're especially
young people of color especially young
black and Latino Americans and so we
should view these people these young
black and Latino voters who are trying
to decide whether to vote and swing
voters in the way we view these people
who are trying to decide between whether
to vote for let's say Trump or Biden in
the general election in other words to
view them both as swing voters is to
view them both in a way that okay we
need to persuade these people they're
not political cattle we're not just
gonna turn them out we need to encourage
and persuade them and then we also for
these other swing voters need to make it
easier for them to vote and typically
these young people of color it's the
hardest for them to vote because of
voter suppression policies
thank you you brawn well we're gonna
come to a close of this interview but
I'd love to ask you to read something
that you wrote a couple of days ago on
Instagram you wrote this beautiful
caption on a photo of your daughter and
I'm wondering if you'd be willing to
share that with us and and briefly tell
us how we can each take this perspective
into our own lives
sure
so yeah posted a picture of my my
four-year-old daughter Imani and in the
caption I wrote I love and because I
love I resist there have been many
theories on what's fueling the growing
demonstrations against racism in public
and private let me offer another one
love we love we know the lives of our
loved ones especially our black loved
ones are endangered under the violence
of racism people ask me all the time
what fuels mean it is the same love love
of this little girl love of all the
little and big people who want who I
want to live full lives in the fullness
of their humanity not barred by racists
policy he's not degraded by racist ideas
not terrorized by racist violence let us
be anti-racist let us defend life let us
defend our human rights to live and live
fully because we love and you know Chloe
I just wanted to sort of emphasize that
you know at the heart of being
anti-racist is is love is loving one's
country loving one's you loving one's
humanity loving once relatives and
family and friends and and certainly
loving one so and and you know I
consider love to be a verb I consider
love to be I'm helping another and even
myself to constantly grow into a better
form of myself of themselves that
they've expressed who they want to be
and until to love this country into
humanity is to push humanity
constructively to be a better form of
itself and and there's no way we're
going to be a better form there's no way
we can build a better humanity while we
still have on the shackles of racism hey
that's so beautiful I appreciate
everything you've shared even might feel
like it's made it really good this is
not an easy fix right this is there is
no band-aid option here that will make
this go away
this takes work for all of us and I
really appreciate all of the honesty and
thoughtfulness issues brought to this
today oh you're welcome thank you so
much for for having this conversation
with me thank you so much you bro we're
really grateful to you for joining us
thank you